vous avez voulu faire venir Laurent
Ruquier sur C8 c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est rouge qui est sur C8 on a on en a
discuté tous les deux euh voilà c'était
pour qu'il fasse un magazine voilà comme
il a l'habitude de faire après c'est
vrai que c'est un petit peu tôt cette
année mais la prend pas elle est
toujours en cours la prochaine fois je
n'hésiterai pas à faire que j'aime
beaucoup je l'ai jamais caché ici je
trouve qu'il sait tout faire et voilà je
on sait très bien et j'aurais aimé qui
voilà j'aurais aimé après c'est vrai que
pour l'instant c'est un peu tôt mais
peut-être que l'année prochaine ou
l'année d'après vous inquiétez pas vous
aurez j'aimerais bien manger
Michel Drucker c'est toujours ouvert
pour lui faire signer 2 ans Patrick
Sébastien voilà il est déjà chez nous
avec des rediff mais j'aimerais qu'il
fasse voilà il y a des nouvelles de
nouvelles émissions on est en train de
on va en parler avec Patrick mais c'est
vrai que voilà c'est producteur mais
voilà je je j'adore oui vous expliquer
qu'il y aura face à Baba toutes les deux
semaines donc avec des invités
politiques mais aussi de la société
civile pour faire l'événement toutes les
deux Antoine voilà Antoine il aurait pu
faire aussi face à Baba avec moi voilà
avec plein
que j'ouvrir voilà vous serez pas invité
mais peut-être
vous évoquez de nous deux chroniqueurs
vous avez on avait parlé ici de Marlène
Chapa mais vous évoquez aussi
Jean-Baptiste jabbary oui le ministre
des Transports oui voilà non mais après
comme j'ai dit j'ai dit Jean-Baptiste je
le vois bien dans Danse avec les stars
je pense qu'il a très envie de faire
Danse avec les stars mais c'est vrai
qu'il serait génial là-dedans je
j'espère qu'il va le faire voilà mais
non pas sur la table c'est vrai que j'ai
toujours dit Marlène Schiappa je trouve
que c'est pas c'est la dernière fois
qu'on en avait parlé il y avait pas
encore eu l'annonce du nouveau
gouvernement du coup est-ce que c'est
encore ouvert ou on va en discuter voilà
je vais la voir mais pour l'instant
Marlène elle est sur d'autres projets
mais voilà on s'est en tout cas
quelqu'un c'est toujours ouvert aussi
ouais je pense qu'elle serait très bonne
chroniqueuse
qui arrivait vous allez bien voir les
informations complémentaires sur votre
avenir sur parce que parce que le
Parisien
[Rires]
on va on parlera après
pour l'instant on avance on est on
avance voilà on joue on avance on a
qu'on réalise pas ce qu'on réalise pas
c'est que dans une signature là en
avance c'est pas fait ça peut capoter
puisque c'est pas fait
ton propre patron
on est en train d'en parler avec les
dirigeants
prochainement prochaine 48 heures vous
parlez toujours de nouvelles têtes dans
TPMP au moins des gens que vous
souhaiteriez avoir même s'ils viennent
pas ou qui
font que vous avez pas parlé tellement
il y en aura toujours des gens en tête
non j'ai des gens en tête j'ai des gens
en tête
j'ai des gens en tête ils sont au
courant les gens en tête oui j'ai déjà
contacté je vous le dis la jeune fille
voilée qui est venue la dernière fois
j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé très bien
on va la tester d'accord
il y aura pas de professionnel voilà ce
sera toujours vous êtes au public
on interview vous tracez les contours de
la saison prochaine mais vous faites
aussi le bilan de Touche pas à mon poste
cette saison et c'est vrai que vous êtes
hyper positif on a l'impression que
cette saison elle a vraiment été je sais
pas si c'est au delà que vous espérons
mais en tout cas vous avez adoré cette
saison
record en audience et records vraiment
on s'amuse on s'amuse beaucoup tout va
bien vraiment on est content de se
retrouver et d'ailleurs j'en parlerai
tout à l'heure parce que c'est vrai
voilà je vous dirai je vous dirai tout à
l'heure un petit peu voilà comment je
vois les choses pour pour l'année
prochaine
la formule de cheveux
avec le quotidien
et je le dis
à part trois quatre émissions comme
vraiment je le dis direct dormir chez
vous ça c'est votre truc voilà il se
passe quelque chose aujourd'hui je
trouve que la télé en télé que ça dort
j'adore énormément il ne se passe rien
je trouve que quotidien qu'on aime ou
qu'on n'aime pas quotidien quotidien
propose quelque chose qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs et franchement je trouve qu'ils
font du bon boulot je l'ai je trouve
nous aussi on propose quelque chose
qu'on ne doit pas ailleurs à l'époque
moi je me rappelle Cauet proposé quelque
chose qu'on va pas dire aujourd'hui même
tous les nouveaux formats qu'on voit sur
TF1 sur France 2 c'est à part M6 qui
prend des risques et qui nous sort des
pépites voilà le reste franchement c'est
chiant à mourir je suis désolé de vous
dire ça voilà il y a ici on se retrouve
et si on se retrouve il y a j'irai
dormir chez vous il y a quotidien pour
moi il y a TPMP et puis le reste
franchement je trouve qu'il se passe
rien c'est c'est la tristesse après
j'aime bien l'équipe aussi L'Équipe TV
je trouve qu'il se passe des choses
voilà il y a des il y a des talons mais
sinon voilà dans les grandes chaînes je
trouve que c'est la torpeur absolue et
vraiment je trouve que vraiment tous les
formats sont vieux il se passe rien
c'est ils sont tous ils sont tous
chiants voilà je veux dire la vérité et
on en peut plus moi de The Voice tout ça
je suis au bout de je suis au bout du
rouleau j'en peux plus on en peut plus
on en peut plus de The Voice Danse avec
les stars danse
je peux plus moi tout ça je peux me
permettre vous avez racheté une société
et ce que vous proposez vous-même c'est
que des anciennes
Stark machin tout ça la dernière fois
moi j'ai rien racheté moi je suis là
mais votre groupe propose pas de grandes
des trucs qui bougent oui mais parce que
je ne veux rien c'est compliqué le
programme et j'aimerais que vraiment
alors ils ont donc c'est plein de
nouveaux trucs à chaque fois qu'ils ont
lancé des nouveaux trucs ça s'est planté
ils ont lancé plein de choses regardez
on a vu plein de trucs à part massinger
il y a rien qui marche ils ont lancé
plein de trucs même avec voilà avec
plein d'animateurs à chaque fois c'est
c'est la torpeur absolue alors après moi
j'aime bien aussi voilà je dis voilà
Jean-Luc Reichmann je le dis dans
l'interview là même quelque chose voilà
il amène un truc c'est vrai que c'est
quelqu'un voilà c'est il amène un truc
Nagui aussi